playstation is planning to launch 10
live service games by 2026 uncharted and
fortnite might have a collaboration
coming soon and more
sony's 3.6 billion acquisition of
destiny developer bungie is the big news
this week and now playstation boss
harmon holst has shed some more light on
the deal and what it means for the
future appearing on the official
playstation podcast hulse said bungie
has succeeded and prospered in the live
service category which is no easy task
sony wants to do much more in the space
and just announced plans to launch 10
live service games by 2026 so snapping
up bungie aligned with its goals holst
also had praise for bungie's first big
series which is owned by microsoft halo
which he said is one of the best shooter
franchises ever but destiny goes even
further in holst's eyes
also during the interview huls clarified
that he is unable to touch on specifics
as it relates to the collaborative
opportunities between playstation and
bungie because the deal isn't signed yet
but hull said he has worked with
bungie's jason jones and pete parsons
for some time already and he's excited
to do more which would all seem to line
up well considering bungie is already
working on a new ipv for 2025. no
further details were shared about the 10
new titles but with 2026 only being four
years away it looks like we're gonna see
a lot more announcements coming soon
according to new leaks it looks like
sony pictures uncharted movie might make
an appearance in fortnight soon twitter
user egyptian leaker seemingly
discovered an unreleased fortnight
challenge within the game files that
read collect treasure using an uncharted
treasure map this suggests that the
live-action uncharted movie starring tom
holland and mark wahlberg as nathan
drake and victor sully sullivan could be
coming to the battle royale the
challenge is apparently set to go live
one day before the release of the movie
on february 18th so an announcement from
epic games could be coming soon
additionally the leaker also later found
two encrypted male characters skins
codenamed sleek as well as a special
item shop background for both of them
earlier this month it was reported that
epic games signed a deal with paramount
to make use of the teenage mutant ninja
turtles and several other intellectual
properties within the game so don't
expect this possible uncharted crossover
to be the last time you see movie
characters show up in fortnite
rocksteady's suicide squad killed the
justice league is reportedly delayed
until next year the report comes via
bloomberg's jason schreier who cites the
news to people familiar with the game's
development no specific reason for the
delay was given and publisher warner
brothers has yet to officially comment
on the game's alleged delay warner
media's chief executive officer jason
killer tweeted just last week that
warner would be releasing a full slate
of highly anticipated games in 2022
including upcoming games like the harry
potter rpg hogwarts legacy and batman
spin-off gotham knights the tweet
notably did not mention suicide squad
which live service games are you playing
right now and do we even have time for
10 more let me know your thoughts on
that in the comments but enough about
things that are on the way the
long-awaited fan remaster of resident
evil 4 is available today and honestly
it looks amazing consider this an
official psa to check it out and of
course thank you for watching leave a
like subscribe and come back tomorrow
for another episode of gamespot news
[Music]
you